elle est noble ambition merci madame la
parole est un monsieur vincent ledoux
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre la
justice monsieur le ministre on apprend
aux étudiants en droit que temis la
célèbre déesse grecque aux yeux bandés
symbolise l'impartialité de la justice
je crains que ce récit ne doivent être
actualisés car madame taubira on a fait
une déesse aveuglés par excès de laxisme
et de précaution nous sommes aux
urgences de tourcoing dans la nuit du 15
au 16 octobre
quand des médecins et des infirmiers
sont brutalement agressés par une
famille de quinze personnes menaces et
insultes se poursuivront jusque dans le
tribunal ou les agresseurs paraissent en
comparution immédiate ils obtiennent le
renvoi de leur affaire merci madame
taubira ce 7 novembre stupéfaction le
tribunal estime que cette affaire ne
peut être jugé en l'état et demande un
complément d'enquêté
le format de la comparution immédiate
n'était-il pourtant pas suffisant pour
établir la matérialité de faits avérés
comme l'a estimé le parquet cas
prendrons-nous d'autres des victimes que
l'apport aux ventes qui les taraude
depuis cette nuit sauvage
aujourd'hui la parole de médecins
vaut-elle moins que celle de voyous bien
connu le soignant ne devrait il pas au
contraire bénéficié d'une présomption
quand on vient l'agressé au coeur même
de son sanctuaire professionnels qu'à
prendrons-nous de nouveau des agresseurs
réfugier dans une victimisation lâche et
indigne
il faut être sérieux tout de même
doutons nous du fait que les soignants
sont les victimes dans cette affaire
cette reconnaissance devait être
immédiate quand cette prolongation du
temps judiciaire vient semer un doute
intolérable
entendez vous monsieur le ministre
l'incompréhension et la souffrance de
nos urgentistes tourquennois
entendez-vous la colère de nos
concitoyens qui peine à croire dans
cette justice qu'en les délinquants
exonéré de tout contrôle judiciaire sont
libres de tout mouvement au sein même du
quartier hospitalier entendez-vous la
colère de nos policiers ils se sentent
dévalorisés
quand on doute de leur travail la
procédure va être longue très longue des
mois certainement
je vous demande donc monsieur le
ministre de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
diligenter cette affaire qui n'a que
trop duré et surtout ne pas faire mentir
la promesse au mali mme touraine qui
réclament et rizières si l'enfant est à
monsieur jean jacques urvoas
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député le doubs je vous remercie de vous
faire le relais de l'émoi des personnels
pour les faits qui sont intervenus
effectivement à l'hôpital de tourcoing
et qui sont inqualifiables
ce n'est pas parce que l'hôpital public
est un lieu ouvert que la violence doit
être accepté et naturellement que la
sanction pénale sera à la hauteur de ce
que vous avez dénoncé à juste titre je
ne commente pas les décisions de justice
je ne commente pas les affaires en cours
monsieur le député et donc je suis au
regret de vous dire que l'effet que vous
avez évoquées sont factuellement juste
il respecte la procédure
madame taubira n'a rien à voir dans le
fait que quand un avocat demande le
report d'un dossier quand on est en
comparution immédiate
ces deux droits et ce n'est pas de
droits depuis trois ans
c'est depuis de droit depuis que la
procédure existe donc l'avocat demandait
qu'à fait le parquet le parquet au
regard de la gravité des faits parce que
ces faits sont extrêmement graves
deux internes et un médecin hospitalier
agressé dans une enceinte hospitalière
ce n'est pas tolérable
au regard de la gravité des faits et du
parcours pénal des individus qui ont été
interpellés par les services de police
qui ont été requis immédiatement je les
remercie pour leur efficacité
le parquet a réclamé douze mois ce sont
des peines extrêmement fermes sur le
député 12 mois d'imprimantes
d'emprisonnement ferme pour le premier
celui qui avait été identifié notamment
qu'en étant le porter des coups et de 12
mois pour les deux autres personnes qui
étaient aussi prévenu le juge
et encore une fois je ne commente pas
les décisions de justice le juge a
estimé au regard de la complexité de la
sphère qu'il fallait un complément
d'enquêté le parquet a ouvert
aujourd'hui une information judiciaire
les prévenus ont été placés sous
contrôle judiciaire
il commet ils viendront donc devant la
juridiction une fois que l'effet auront
été établi que les témoins auraient
entendu que les preuves seront avérées
je ne doute pas un instant et vous non
plus monsieur le député puisque vous
avez eu le plaisir d'avoir le procureur
par intérim au téléphone pour évoquer
cette affaire
je ne doute pas que les sanctions sur
leur hauteur des faits commis